c'est la belle endormie des hauts de
bienne une vieille bâtisse du 19e siècle
au lustre passé un hôtel-restaurant
d'aussi loin qu'on s'en souvienne
voilà la grande pièce de restauration
donc un plus de 100 couverts pouvait
être dressé les derniers propriétaires
ont baissé le rideau il y a quatre ans
après une lente agonie la fin d'un
symbole celui du temps de plus en plus
lointain où l'économie était florissante
ça a été un crève coeur parce que
c'était quand même un haut lieu pour
mort est un aussi bien pour le tourisme
que pour l'économie locale
voilà les les chefs d'entreprise
recevait beaucoup leurs clients ici
et puis aussi c'était une halte pour
tous ceux qui travaillaient avec les
usines localement alors le maire et son
conseil ont eu une idée vu son morel
ville de trésors utiliser le magot des
jo b cette vieille famille mauricienne
qui cachait lingots et pièces d'or dans
des pots de confiture dans
l'arrière-boutique de sa drogue y
racheté l'an dernier par la ville
une manne inespérée pour un projet un
peu fou rouvrir un hôtel restaurant haut
de gamme pour la clientèle suisse et les
touristes en hôtellerie dans quoi le
tourisme c'est parce que ce qu'il fait
découvrir le plus dans une ville
sinistrée où les enseignes ferment les
unes après les autres et où le dernier
commerce d'alimentation générale est en
passe de déménager pour la commune
voisine
le projet divise et il est loin d'être
bouclé en gros le volume achats plus
rénovation donc en fonction du nombre de
chambres entre 16 et 24 c entre 2
millions et 2 millions 5 et l'apport du
trésor est estimée aujourd'hui à 650000
euros
donc il en manque vous voyez des études
de faisabilité sont en cours qui
conditionneront la validation de l'achat
manquent également des partenaires qui
pourraient émettre des réserves bien
avant d'ouvrir
ovation